our company is now
meta when you hear a tech buzzword like
the metaverse it's easy to tune it out
as just another marketing stunt but i
think the metaverse actually represents
a really important vision for the future
of technology you can't get too hung up
on the word metaverse though since we
probably won't be using that term for
long after all do you know anyone who
refers to the internet as the
information super highway obviously not
but many of the predictions about the
information superhighway were
surprisingly accurate and i think that
we will eventually see the same thing
for the metaverse but the real question
is when when will vr actually be good
enough to use for more than a few hours
at a time
when will the average person start
caring about digital goods and when will
computers become powerful enough to
finally create a persistent virtual
world these are tough questions and it's
not as simple as just looking at a
particular company's roadmap and
estimating when they will ship a
specific product we're talking about an
era so it's best to think of the arrival
as the metaverse in terms of a shift in
behavior just like the internet isn't a
single place but instead a collection of
websites applications and services that
work together the metaverse just
describes a collection of technologies
business models and interactions that
will look very different from today's
internet if we want to try and guess
when the metaverse will arrive we'll
need to pinpoint the moment at which the
digital world becomes more meaningful to
most people than the physical world
artificial intelligence researchers use
the concept of the singularity to
describe a moment when technological
growth becomes uncontrollable and
irreversible essentially once an ai
system can improve itself beyond human
capabilities these improvements will
start compounding endlessly and create a
super intelligence that surpasses all of
humanity that's still a long way off but
if you look at how people interact with
the digital world it feels like the
metaverse moment could be right around
the corner our focus on the physical
world has been declining for decades
work has moved from conference rooms to
video calls friendships are increasingly
formed online through twitter and
discord communities and video games are
quickly replacing sports as the dominant
competitive activity this trend is more
than just our activities though it's now
about identity and individualism
metaverse will be the successor to the
mobile internet we'll be able to feel
present like we're right there with
people no matter how far apart we
actually are there are lots of people
that care deeply about their online
personas just look at any instagram
influencer and you'll see a perfectly
curated timeline of events portraying an
idealized lifestyle new technologies
have been shifting our attention for
decades now the physical world used to
be our only option but then things
started to change tvs pulled a few hours
of our attention then computers took
more and then phones allowed us to bring
the digital world with us wherever we
went there are currently 4.6 billion
internet users globally that's more than
half of the people on earth we're firmly
in the internet age now but only a small
fraction of those people are fully
immersed in the digital world a few
weeks ago a crypto founder named richard
turned down a 9.5 million dollar offer
for his crypto punk nft even though
that's a staggering amount of money for
a single profile picture richard said
that the image was now tied to his
identity and simply wasn't for sale this
is a perfect example of someone who has
already crossed over into metaverse
territory this might sound terrible and
dystopian to you or it might sound
amazing and futuristic the good news is
that you'll have a choice there are
still three billion people who don't use
the internet after all and plenty of
people choose to deactivate their
facebook accounts every single day
regardless of how the idea of moving
into an even more online world makes you
feel it's still worthwhile to try and
predict when this might happen when will
we see billions of people fully immerse
themselves in digital spaces in order to
estimate when it will be apparent that
the metaverse has arrived we need to lay
some ground rules because i've seen a
lot of heated debates on this topic
first we need to agree that the
metaverse describes a future state and
it isn't already here i've seen a few
people argue that second life or
roadblocks are already metaverses and we
should just stop the discussion there
it's great to look at these two games as
examples of what's possible but neither
are fully immersive the metaverse will
obviously build on top of what second
life and roblox have done and i wouldn't
be surprised if roblox in particular
plays an essential role in the metaverse
going forward but it's just not fair to
say that the metaverse is already here
and call it a day after all we had
cellphones in the 1980s but no one
claims that the mobile era started then
the average person in the 80s didn't
even have a laptop and real smartphone
innovation wouldn't pick up until the
mid-2000s we also need to agree that the
metaverse is possible and that it'll
only happen if people actually like it
mark zuckerberg isn't exactly the most
popular guy in tech these days and
plenty of his detractors have said that
they would never use products created by
facebook or the rebranded meta that's a
totally fine position to have consumers
will always have particular brand
preferences just look at all the android
versus iphone debates if anything the
rivalry between the two major mobile
phone operating systems actually helped
phones become ubiquitous no one could
stop talking about which phone was best
which drew a lot of attention the
metaverse will be bigger than any one
company and zuckerberg recognizes this
we're talking about an entirely new
computing era here not just a particular
product or service making the metaverse
a reality will require a collection of
technological advances virtual reality
and augmented reality have to get better
systems and networks need to start
talking to one another and the internet
clearly needs to get faster but all of
that is possible we're not talking about
crazy brain computing interfaces here
like elon musk's neural link or plugging
into something that perfectly recreates
the matrix all of the ideas laid out in
ready player 1 seem pretty feasible to
me even if it will take quite some time
to get there so the oasis serves as a
pretty good point of reference let's
take a minute to focus just on the
hardware requirements of the metaverse
eventually there will be lots of
different ways to interface with virtual
environments but i still think virtual
reality headsets are absolutely critical
here from a casual observer's
perspective it can look like vr
development has really stalled out over
the past few years in 2012 everyone in
tech obsessed over the original oculus
rift palmer lucky was the perfect
founder and quickly became the poster
boy for all of vr all while releasing
dramatic improvements at a breakneck
pace fast forward to 2021 and facebook
is still releasing new versions of the
oculus but each iteration feels more
incremental they've only sold a few
million of them which is nothing
compared to the nearly 3 billion people
who use facebook but it's important to
understand that zuckerberg has a very
particular strategy here because he's
targeting such a large audience he
really isn't working on shipping ultra
high-end headsets to the general public
but fortunately other companies are the
vario xr3 is a great example of what's
possible in vr when money isn't an issue
the headset costs six thousand dollars
up front and requires a fifteen hundred
dollar per year subscription on top of
that it's not made with average
consumers in mind but it's a great
demonstration of where this technology
is going the first consumer oculus
launched in 2016 and has a resolution of
a little over one megapixel per eye
which wasn't terrible but it did lead to
some clearly noticeable pixelation the
oculus quest 2 which came out last year
serves up about three and a half
megapixels per eye which is roughly
equivalent to 4k but even that isn't
enough for true immersion the vario xr3
on the other hand pushes well beyond
this by using multiple screens stacked
on top of each other to deliver more
than 11 megapixels per eye these aren't
perfect apples to apples comparisons
since there are tons of other factors
that go into making a vr experience feel
truly immersive but it's a solid step
forward just watch the reaction of this
vr enthusiast i don't even know what to
say
everything looks so clear and so real
you have to try this this vario headset
has lidar sensors and can be used for
augmented reality as well it also
improves on field of view which is a
huge part of a good experience the
display of the second hololens from
microsoft covers only 52 degrees and
snap's new ar glasses are only 26
degrees this vario headset delivers 115
degrees of view meaning that you can see
more of your surroundings in your
peripheral vision which is key to
immersion obviously the average consumer
isn't going to spend thousands of
dollars on a vr headset anytime soon but
this tech will get cheaper and when it
does we should see adoption start to
climb there are also a host of other
technologies that need to improve before
the metaverse really starts pulling
people in even though zuckerberg painted
an incredibly optimistic picture of what
this new focus might accomplish it was
john carmack the chief technology
officer of oculus that actually had the
most valuable presentation during the
meta announcement even though carmack
works directly for zuckerberg he was
very sober in his analysis i have been
pretty actively arguing against every
single metaverse effort you know i want
it to exist but i have pretty good
reasons to believe that go setting out
to build the metaverse is not actually
the best way to wind up with the
metaverse that's an interesting
perspective especially coming from
someone who's been working at facebook
in vr for the last seven years but it
makes sense because the metaverse is
such a broad amalgamation of
technologies it's impossible for any one
company to usher in the metaverse era
alone but that doesn't mean that a
single company can't have a profound
impact here and make a boatload of money
in the process i believe that zuckerberg
is basically trying to be the next steve
jobs and to do it he needs his iphone
moment the iphone was a major turning
point in ushering in the mobile era
there were tons of other companies that
played important roles but it was really
the iphone that brought everything
together and served as the key turning
point and the history of apple is really
important here in the 1980s the
macintosh was struggling to compete with
the ibm pc and so the board of directors
fired jobs he eventually rejoined apple
in 1997 and started working on new
projects finally in 2007 he announced
the iphone at the end of a keynote using
his now famous line wait a minute there
is one more thing one more thing but
there is one more thing but there is
one more thing i think that there are a
few interesting comparisons between jobs
and zuckerberg worth discussing here
first is the redemptive story that zuck
is building around the metaverse he's
been the subject of intense negative
attention for years now and lots of
people have been calling for him to step
down fortunately for zuck he has
complete control over the company and a
very supportive board of directors so i
don't think we'll see a repeat of the
steve jobs story play out exactly but
don't think for a moment that zuck
doesn't care what people think about him
he really does want to create products
that are adored by users 91 of people
view apple favorably compared to just 71
for facebook and so he's on the hunt for
a big win in the metaverse it might be
vr it might be a new social platform or
it might be something entirely new but
zuck is clearly restructuring the entire
company to be able to try as many ideas
as possible i think this is a good
strategy but the messaging around zuck's
meta announcement could not have been
more different than job's iphone keynote
even though he borrowed the signature
one more thing line there's one more
thing that i want to tell you about
today see when steve jobs announced the
iphone it was ready to ship he wasn't
talking about a far-off future where
mobile phones were used daily by
billions of people in fact the first
iphone didn't even have an app store and
apple had been incredibly tight-lipped
about the fact that they were working on
a phone before the announcement jobs
never mentioned how important mobile was
going to be to apple until they were
ready to launch a polished product and
that's part of why it's so hard to nail
down exactly when we'll hit the tipping
point and be able to confidently say
that we are in the metaverse era there
are so many different products and
companies gradually improving technology
and increasing immersiveness but it
might only be clear in retrospect what
the key ingredients were even still i
think there are some interesting
comparisons we can make to try and
project metaverse adoption first is vr
headsets this year we should see about 6
million new sales which will bring the
total number of headsets out in the
world up to 16 million units that's
still incredibly low remember there are
billions of internet users but growth is
high at 60 per year and if it continues
we could see 1 billion headsets in
circulation by 2030. you could also look
at cryptocurrency adoption rates since
crypto will likely play a big role in
the metaverse long term metamask is the
fastest growing ethereum wallet and a
critical part of the defy ecosystem
there are millions of people who want
nothing to do with zuck's metaverse and
will only accept a decentralized option
metamask usage is a good proxy for the
size of this audience and it's growing
even faster than vr the wallet had half
a million users in july of 2020 and just
crossed 10 million users in august of
2021 that works out to an insane 20x
annual growth rate which is clearly
unsustainable but it doesn't seem crazy
to think that we could see close to a
billion cryptocurrency users by the end
of the decade bitcoin is already used by
over 100 million people after all lastly
we can look at zuckerberg's plan
specifically he's aiming to deploy a 180
billion dollars over the next 10 years
on the initiative so he's obviously
going to have some sort of impact for
reference a senior apple executive said
that they spent only 150 million to
develop the original iphone 180 billion
dollars is a staggering amount of money
truly unprecedented in the tech industry
if meta winds up spreading that evenly
over the next 10 years they will be
spending 50 times as much money as the
entire roblox team every single year
zuckerberg clearly thinks he can have a
meaningful impact in the next 10 years
and has reconfigured his entire business
to make something happen we still don't
know exactly what the next decade we'll
have in store for the metaverse but you
can be sure that some interesting things
will happen here if you'd like to go a
layer deeper just drop your email at
johncoogan.com and please check out this
recommended video the youtube algorithm
thinks you'll really like it